-Oh, my God.
You know what I forgot?
-What did -- What did you --
-I forgot how bouncy
these chairs were.
Every time I'm here,
I always remember.
-Are they bouncy?
-They are so bouncy.
-I've never really sat in them.
Well, let me try.
Do you want to sit in my chair?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, you can sit here --
-I would love to.
Let me see if this --
how bouncy this is.
Ooh, yeah.
Pretty bouncy.
Yeah, you're right.
-Whoa.
-How's it feel?
-Feels great to be Jimmy.
[ Laughter ]
-It feels great to be Noah.
How -- how you doing, bud?
-I'm doing good.
Welcome back to the show.
[ Laughter ]
-Thanks for having me.
Look at this great crowd.
I love these guys.
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Um...
I heard -- I heard you're going
to school in the fall.
-I am. I'm going to college.
-Wow. Good for you, bud.
Now, was that always the plan?
-Are we doing a switch?
Or am I staying here?
-Yeah, you can do the switch
if you want, yeah.
-All right. Go back.
[ Laughter ]
What?
-Yeah, why not? This -- we'll
keep switching chairs
the whole thing.
-Okay.
-Where are you going to school?
-I'm going to
the University of Pennsylvania.
-Yo! Good for you.
-Yeah. Very exciting.
-What are you majoring in?
What are you studying?
-I'm majoring in business
and entrepreneurship.
So -- yeah, so I'll be minoring
in like, film,
and taking film classes,
of course. I have to.
-You've done film, yeah, so --
-Yeah.
-You might study yourself.
[ Laughter ]
That'd be amazing.
-Oh, my God.
-Yeah, imagine
if you're studying yourself.
-That would be crazy.
-But that's pretty fun.
-Yeah, and I'd just love to
learn about, like,
building businesses.
And I just recently launched
a product.
-What products
have you launched?
-It's called TBH. It's like
a healthy Nutella kind of thing.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah, I love Nutella,
but it's -- it's bad for you,
so I made it healthy.
-So you made a healthy Nutella.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Are you gonna -- are --
you live on campus?
-So, yeah.
So I have a roommate.
And I -- that's one thing I was
actually very excited about,
was -- was having --
living in a dorm.
Like, what is that like?
-Does -- Does your roommate know
that it's you
moving in with him?
-Yeah. Yeah. We -- We talked.
And he's, like --
he's cool about it. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, he's going to be
the most popular kid in school.
-Really?
-Yes, of course.
I mean, dude, you're
Noah Schnapp, come on.
-Okay. I mean, it -- we're --
he -- his like, parents know
my parents and everything.
So it's, like...
-You know, I -- I follow you
on all the socials.
I know you're on the Instagram,
you're on Twitter.
You have 20 million on each one.
@NoahSchnapp.
He's a good follow, by the way.
And you said that TikTok
is your favorite app.
-Yeah. I feel like it's just
the most, like, authentic.
Like, you can be the most real.
It's just not -- Instagram's
so fake, I feel like.
And I -- I just, I love how
funny and authentic TikTok is.
And there's actually a debate
going on, on TikTok.
-Okay.
-Have you heard about
the wheels or doors?
-Oh, yeah.
-Have you guys heard about this?
-Audience: Yeah!
-All right, so there's a debate.
What -- What is it now, again?
-So -- So, someone created
this debate, if --
whether there's more doors
or wheels in the world.
What -- what is your stance
before I -- before I make my --
-Are there more doors or wheels?
-Just, in the entire world.
-Well, I'm much older than you,
Noah.
I've lived a long life,
and I will tell you that...
-Okay.
-There are more wheels
than there are doors.
-Okay, team wheels.
Me, too.
-Wait, you're team wheels?
-Yeah, yeah.
-Right?
-I feel like -- I just --
I think if you just think
about suitcases and strollers
and cars, trucks --
-Suitcases and strollers.
-I'm ready to fight anyone
who says doors.
-Wow! All right.
This is very good.
We're team wheels.
-Yeah, I'm glad we agree.
-Never forget, buddy.
Team wheels, yeah.
-I'm just saying.
I'm team, like -- I mean, yo.
-No.
-You're talking about doors
versus wheels, I mean.
-No! Kick -- Get him out.
-Now, listen -- find me --
Let's just take a building.
Like, okay --
-Okay, but a building,
think about every --
every office has a --
Every -- there's office chairs.
They all have five wheels
on them.
-Not all of them.
Not all of them.
But every --
-Then they have six wheels!
-Every -- Every office
has doors.
-And every office
has office chairs.
And think about cars.
Think about --
-Every car has doors.
Every car has doors.
-This is out of control.
-Tariq, most doors --
-Absolutely not.
-Most doors have handles.
And on those handles are wheels.
-Get out of here!
-Think about conveyor belts.
[ Laughter ]
Yes, Jimmy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Boo!
-We -- We've got to count it up,
man.
Tally -- Tally --
-I -- I want to talk about
"Stranger Things"
before you leave, okay?
"Stranger Things" season four.
I know you can't give away
any spoilers.
Everyone's so excited
about this thing.
Congrats.
-Thank you.
-You're great.
I know they're coming back
for season five,
and they're kind of wrapping
it up in season five.
-Oh, my God. I mean,
they just --
they recently posted this letter
that they wrote,
which I never saw
until they post it.
'Cause they don't really tell us
anything.
'Cause they know I'm --
I'm always spoiling stuff.
So, they -- they -- they put out
this letter,
and it was like,
"The show's ending, that's it.
This is the beginning
of the end."
And I read it
and I was just bawling.
I was so upset.
And I texted Millie --
my castmate, who plays Eleven.
-Of course.
-And she was like --
she was like,
"You're crying too?"
Like, "So am I."
And then she texted Gaten,
who also plays Dustin,
and he was like,
"I'm crying too."
And then we all texted
The Duffers and we were like,
"This is so sad.
Like, I can't believe
this is over."
And they were like, "You guys
gotta stop texting us.
Like, I -- I know it's over,
but -- but we have time left."
But it's --
-Yeah, and they started crying.
[ Laughter ]
-They were crying.
-Were they -- yeah.
-I mean, I --
-'Cause that was your whole
childhood, really.
-It's crazy.
I mean, I grew up on the show.
-You did.
-I -- I've been on it --
I auditioned for it
when I was 9.
I'm now, like,
turning 18 this year.
-That's wild, buddy, right?
-Yeah, so --
-That's gonna be insane.
-It's -- It's --
-Well, you did a great job,
and everyone does a great job
on there, buddy.
And -- and you too, yeah.
Before you cry, come back,
and we'll --
we'll talk about the show more.
It's not over, it's not over.
-Okay, you're right, you're
right. We have one more season.
-If you could do this for me,
though --
in one word,
could you describe season four?
-I would say chaos.
Complete and utter chaos.
I would say it -- it's
everywhere and has everything
and doesn't miss a beat.
-'Cause it looks like everyone's
in different spots.
-Everyone's spread out
everywhere.
It's -- It's just the craziest,
biggest thing
you've seen
from "Stranger Things."
-I will take that.
Noah Schnapp everybody!
One of our pals.
Volume one of "Stranger Things"
season four
begins streaming May 27th.
We'll be right back with a
performance from Nilufer Yanya.
Stick around everybody.
-♪ 4 and 3 and 2 and 1 ♪
♪ See them shots when they hear
the boot scoot and turn ♪
♪ Down with my fellow,
Questlove and y'all ♪
♪ I got more rhymes than
Fab Freddy got paint ♪
♪ Got rhymes that's rough
and some rhymes that's nasty ♪